In this problem, a 600 megawatt coal
fired power plant operates at full
capacity with a thermal efficiency of
32%.
The plant uses Illinois basin coal with
a heating value of 11,800
BTUs per pound. The following emission
factors are provided.
The NOX emission factor is 85 lb per
ton.
The SO2 emission factor is 72 pounds per
At full load, the coal consumption rate
is 55 tons per hour. What is most nearly
the NOX emission rate in tons hour?
Okay, so this is an extremely simple
question to solve. In fact, the trick to
this problem is only knowing what to
avoid. So let's make this step one.
The plant is burning 55 tons of coal per
hour.
We are given two emission factors. One
for nitrogen oxides or NOx and one for
sulfur dioxide or SO2.
But since the question only cares about
NOx, that SO2 number is just there to
distract us.
We also don't need to know the power
output of the plant, the plant's thermal
efficiency,
or even the heating value of the coal.
Getting rid of all these extra
distractions makes the problem look a
lot more simple.
So, step two,
calculations.
Multiply the coal flow rate by the NOX
emission factor. Then convert that to
tons per hour.
So we have 85
pounds per ton
time
tons per hour.
Finally
times
one ton
over 2,000 lb.
Making sure our units cancel
leaves us with tons per hour, which is
what the problem is asking for. And this
calculates out to just about 2.33
tons hour, which is the closest to our
third answer over here.
Quick multiplication, quick unit
conversion, and we're done. Again, the
real test of this type of problem is not
the math, but knowing what you need and
what you don't. And that's it.